大家看到半導體股漲這麼多,
那第一個直覺一定是本益比是不是已經太貴。
但半導體這種高速成長的產業,
如果你只看 PE 的 Ratio 其實還不夠。
我會把未來的 EPS 成長率一起放進來考慮,
所以我會比較關注 PEG Ratio 本益成長比。
AI 時代來臨,投資也能充滿智慧。
富邦 AI Pro 專業分析資料,透視趨勢,
輕鬆一點掌握全球市場脈動。
有AI投資更Pro
現在就點擊知識欄趕快去下載
今年以來美股在AI奇才帶動下受到市場關注
半導體產業更成為領長主力
面對美股第四季展望
科技巨頭的現金流挑戰
以及市場最關注的估值問題
投資人應該如何佈局呢
本集我們特別邀請到國臺投信的機靈人李翰林
帶我們從市場趨勢以及ETF投資視角
深入解析美國科技產業與半導體產業的真實樣貌
不僅分享未來投資機會
也將告訴我們如何透過ETF跟上半導體產業趨勢
在節目開始之前
也不要忘記按贊訂閱開啟小鈴鐺
才不會錯過最新的節目哦
讓我們歡迎今天的來賓李翰林經理人
經理人你好
主持人好
各位觀眾朋友大家好
今年以來美國科技產業表現強勁
想請問經理人
這波美股與半導體產業的漲勢
主要是由哪些基本面因素所驅動的呢
以及目前市場的評價與股價表現
是否仍與企業獲利成長
與未來的展望相匹配呢
我認為今年的美股
尤其是半導體產業的漲勢
它有個很重要的特色
就是這次不只是只有本益比
評價沒有拉高
獲利也非常快速地在成長
而從第二季以來
美國的經濟數據的公佈的狀況
那就持續地優於市場的預期
但貨幣政策
卻沒有同步而大幅的轉移
所以市場就重新的把注意力
放回企業的基本面
而第二季的財報
其實就有給市場很好的成績單檢驗結果
以標普買指數的成分股財報來看
不只是有87%的公司
公佈優於預期的EPS
其中資訊科技產業
更是獲利成長最快的產業之一
最新預估的獲利年成長率高達63%
但如果我們再看細一點
科技裡面又以半導體和半導體設備的表現最突出
預估獲利年成長率更高達125%
是科技產業裡面最大的貢獻來源
如果把半導體產業剔除的話
那科技產業的預估獲利年成長率
就會下降到24%而已
這代表AI的行情
已經從一開始的追逐題材
開始轉換到聚焦在
有真正營收穫利和現金流的半導體產業上面
那第二個驅動因素
就是AI的資本支出仍然表現相對的強勁
我們以前談AI最直接想到的就是GPU
所以2023、2024年最先受惠的是算力概念股
但到了2025、2026之後
產業開始碰到了新的瓶頸
算力再多 GPU再快
如果記憶體的頻寬不足
GPU還是得慢慢地等資料再傳輸
而高頻寬記憶體HBM
在製造的晶圓消耗與良率的問題
會排擠標準型記憶體DRAN的產能
使AI需求的快速成長
反而造成整個記憶體市場結構性的供應吃緊
所以我們看到半導體的行情
開始從單純的缺GPU堆算力
變成整體AI供應鏈的供需失衡
開始往DRAN NAND HPN ASIC先進封裝來擴散
再進一步到半導體的設備
所以目前美股和半導體乍看之下
是連漲好幾年漲了很多
但並不是典型的股價上漲
但獲利沒跟上的狀況
而是AI的需求快速的成長
在推動股價和獲利同時快速往上
而半導體又是目前獲利成長最強的產業
但也有許多投資人發現
近期部分科技巨頭
因大量投入AI基礎建設
而出現現金流轉付的情況
想請問經理人
請問這是否會可能影響到市場信心
或甚至拖累整體美股後續表現呢
以及第四季的美股市場應該要如何看待呢
科技巨頭短期現金流有壓力是真的沒錯
但需要擔心的並不是亞馬遜和Google
自由現金流變成負數的這件事
而是投入之後到底有沒有產生足夠的營收
科技巨頭到現在確實遇到一個很有趣的現象
就是AI投資非常大
所以資本支出會吃掉很多自由現金流
那我會把這件事情分成兩個階段來看
第一階段叫做建設期
就像蓋大型的建設
比如說蓋高速公路或網際網路
剛開始建設的時候
一定是先砸大量的資本支出
建設好了之後
就會到了第二階段的回收期
那才會產生收入
所以如果今天自由現金流下降
是因為企業拿去蓋資料中心
買GPU 買ASIC 買網路設備
而云端跟AI的營收
用同步的高速成長
那我就不認為這是單純的泡沫
而是前期無可避免的正常支出
而且這反映出
現階段科技巨頭的決策邏輯
是先確保AI算力和資料中心不落人後
短期可能承受自由現金流的壓力
但這證明
未來AI不僅是真的需求
企業普遍預期AI的需求
仍具有商業化的潛力
以及重要的策略價值
值得注意的是
如果KPES還在增加
可是AI營收資料中心的使用率
訂單和ROIC開始往下的情況
但依目前的公開資訊觀察
相關基本面數據仍然是穩健的
因為我們甚至都還沒有看到
KPES在踩剎車
大型CSP的業者
都還是在維持極高的資本支出水準
Google甚至不管自由現金流
已經變成負數
還是持續的上修AI基礎建設投資
但同時雲端和AI的業務
也有在高速成長
所以自由現金流轉負
它不是紅燈
它比較像是黃燈
要注意的紅燈是KPAC繼續增加
但AI的營收、使用率
與投資報酬率開始下降
但這些目前都還沒有看到負面的狀況
如果企業的獲利
和AI相關的需求維持目前的趨勢
那美股第四季市場
有機會獲得基本面的支撐
但短期就可能被這些質疑所衝擊到
所以波動就會放大
加上近期美國和伊朗的衝突狀況還沒解決
導致油價升高
重新帶來通膨和升息的疑慮
表示第四季即使是中期趨勢偏多
也不太可能是一條直線的向上趨勢
隨著AI題材持續發酵
半導體產業股價已累積可觀漲幅
目前整體估值是否已經偏高
未來還有哪些成長動能會值得投資人關注呢
半導體產業如果從絕對估值來看
的確已經不算低
但如果考慮到獲利的成長率
其實就沒有想象中的那麼貴
大家看到半導體股漲這麼多
那第一個直覺一定是本益比是不是已經太貴
但半導體這種高速成長的產業
如果你只看P的Ratio其實還不夠
我會把未來的EPS成長率一起放進來考慮
所以我會比較關注PEG Ratio
本益成長比
相較2022年11月底TripGPT推出之後的高點
GPU ASIC 記憶體 設備 CPU
這些主要的半導體次產業的PEG
其實都已經大幅的下降
那關鍵原因不只是六月底股價開始修正一大段
而是市場對EPS成長率的預估值在大幅的提高
那根據彭博最新的預估
整體廢辦指數明年的EPS成長率高達45.8%
而且這個成長率近年以來是不斷的往上修
但美股大盤標普500指數則只有13.7%
所以其實真正在賺錢公司
主要還是在半導體產業上面
那剛剛提到2023年到2024年
半導體的主要主角是GPU
而現在到均體AI的階段
從訓練到推論更加重要
DSP廠開始增加ASIC
自研加速器
AI算力架構更加多元
而同時遇到的還有記憶體瓶頸的問題
HBM因為堆疊TSP和良率
造成的位元懲罰問題
同樣的經驗的投入
能產生出來的有效bit下降
就會排擠到一般的DRAM供應
而HBN記憶體廠的擴產
又不像過去記憶體中期這麼快
市場目前普遍預估
未來一段期間的供給可能相對會吃緊
但實際情況仍需視產能的擴充進度
以及需求變化而定
HBN從8層、12層走向HBN4的16層
甚至是客製化的HBN4e
會導致TSP時刻薄膜成績檢測這些需求的增加
另一方面3D NAND的層數也繼續往更高層數發展
也會提高高深寬時刻比的設備需求
從製程的演進來看
HBN4的Base Die開始導入邏輯製程
讓控制器的功能移到記憶器的架構當中
加速資料運算處理的效率
並換像是2nm製程以及GAA環繞式雜集
可以防止當電晶體縮小到3奈米以下時
傳統FinFET的底部
所產生嚴重的短通道效應和漏電的狀況
並提升能效比
或是像金貝供電
把電源線路從正面移到背面
讓正面的數據訊號
和背面的電力傳輸互不干擾
這樣就可以解決2奈米以下的
先進製程的電力傳輸瓶頸
並釋放佈線的空間來延續摩爾定律
那這些新制程啊
都會讓單位晶圓的設備投資強度提高
所以自成的升級
也會帶來半導體設備產業的機會
AI半導體產業後續發展
仍有許多值得關注的面向
目前市場關注焦點
已逐步由單一族群
擴展至整體的供應鏈
配存半導體指數被視為
觀察全球半導體產業的重要指標
投資人應該要如何
透過相關的ETF參與成長趨勢呢
相較於投資個股
又具備哪些特色與優勢呢
歷史上每一種新科技的出現
到普及化
包括網際網絡
智慧型手機
和這一輪的AI
都會不斷地提高半導體的使用含量
所以半導體往往是科技創新的
底層基礎建設
是一種成長型的必需品
但是半導體
它跟一般的產業很不一樣
它不是一個單一產品的產業
而是一條非常長的供應鏈
從GPU
ASIC
記憶體
IC設計
代工製造
檢測
測試
封裝
相關設備
甚至是光通訊
細光子
這些都包含在
廢塵半導體指數里面
如果投資人兩年前
只挑GPU
那當時可能很好
沒有錯
但半導體產業的贏家
他是會輪動的
到現在可能變成記憶體
下一階段
也可能輪到設備
ASIC或光通訊
對ETF最大的優勢
就是不用事先猜
下一棒的贏家
會是輪到誰
投資ETF的價值就在於
不必精準的猜對每一個階段的領漲族群
而是把整條AI半導體供應鏈
放到你的投資組合裡
但是要提醒大家
ETF可以降低單一的公司風險
但不能消除產業的風險
半導體產業的波動仍然是高於整體市場的
所以還是要依照自己的風險層速度來做配置
那最後我總結一下現在的AI半導體產業
我認為目前市場的關注焦點
正由部分AI受惠族群
逐步擴展至更多的相關環節
當然後續仍需持續觀察
產業的需求和企業獲利變化
AI一開始出來
市場最關心的是GPU和算力
接下來我們看到
記憶體成為新的瓶頸
D-RAM、NAND、HBM開始受惠
未來再到下一個階段
當記憶體與先進製程都需要擴產
半導體設備又會成為受惠者
甚至再走到光互聯、細光子
發光發熱的階段
所以未來投資半導體最重要的
不一定是要去猜哪一家公司會漲最多
而是要掌握整體的AI產業鏈和基本面
只要AI資本支出和企業獲利
以及最終需求沒有反轉
我認為半導體產業
仍是目前科技產業發展的重要環節
後續發展值得持續關注
謝謝漢玲經理人的分享
AI發展放心為愛
半導體仍是關鍵社會產業
想用ETF參與產業成長
把握下一波投資契機
最後喜歡我們的影片
也不要忘記按贊訂閱開啟小鈴鐺
我們下集再見
拜拜
投資一定有風險
基金投資有賺有賠
存購權應享月公開說明書